[Music]
they spent what a trillion dollars
trying to get one dude back from Mars if
you get the opportunity to bring back
Matt Damon I just don't think we should
wait around to be saved you know you
really don't think they're sending
anybody to save us I
mean in case you haven't noticed we're
doomed to spend the rest of our
miserable lives on this ship maybe we
should do it do what
it we're not attracted now but we would
emotionally attach you mean fall in love
what if this awesome thing we have going
on gets ruined people are meant to be
together oh sorry is this is this on
okay
lame we're both married I'm sure being a
drift in space gives you a h
[Music]
pass you know what you want to watch
tonight alien never seen
it why the hell did we watch that
[Music]
movie